è facilissima da bambino no io sono
vitale però a berlino sta quindi a dorme
ciao anzi nuovo video klein finalmente
non boccia le leggi slime questo non ho
baciato in giù molto particolare ora che
dovremmo fare praticamente dobbiamo
pensare a una parola che un ingrediente
ciao ciao con ingredienti prime la una
persona dovrà cercare di indovinare
quella parola lettera per lettera a un
assolo 6 possibilità se non riesce
perché così tante che il gioco
dell'impiccato così fateci sapere nei
commenti se avete mai giocato al gioco
deliberata braccia corpo abbiamo sei
turni per rifarmi come non provare a
dividere la parola a te l'altra persona
non riesce indovinarla entro sei turni
altra persona che ha deciso la parola
potrà mettere gli ingredienti che vuole
che lo slime
[Musica]
è inverso io non indovino tu potrai
decidere quindi seguito io posso
decidere che cosa ne sarà grato slam
no lo so devo farmi gas e se questo
video raggiunge i 40 mila mi piace
rifaremo questa challenge ma ben date
con gli occhi chiusi al contrario però a
decidere cosa comprare
quindi tendini la parola ti compro
quello che ha indovinato a bormio è
facile basta non andare a comprare al
supermercato di simboli con alamari
direi quindi che indovini la parola lo
compro praticamente sarebbe la challenge
che cosa mi ha verificato che volete
vederla mettetevi comodi e presi pop
corn alla fine del video come sempre
dovrete votare se vinco io timbrò da
oltre vince vitale un confuso ma in base
alla bellezza ai sony a sms dello slam
siete pronti ma te ne vai primo nodo
vediamo chi inizia catapano emilio sasso
[Musica]
questo perché una indizi ok devono
iniziare a provare illuminare qualche
lettera ma ha come unità di una al
centro o o di orso alla fine che cosa
può essere questa cosa provate a
indovinare anche voi nei commenti o la
donna può essere che così tante lettere
e finora non ha perso nessun punto no
non può essere attore ti fa aprire gli
indovini che c'è anche la t go macello
che cosa può essere che mi disse conto
però quelle tombe lo ha eletto
questi coloro che mettono ingrediente
kleinman qualcosa inventato da te vi di
vitale
[Musica]
ci dice lo fa bicarbonato come le faccio
niente del bicarbonato senza colla però
il bicarbonato permette un po nella
ciotola per aspetta sì devo versare ok
non smetterà cosa è chiara mio parola
sette lettere inizia inizio per narrarlo
vuol dire l'audio
mamma mia di nozze provate a indovinare
anche voi un'altra lettera la m di mamma
sì c'è anche la m la rende subito dopo
la prova di dominare le cam betta
non lo so el altra lettera di allora
maglione ma non è che cosa ne sa se tu
provi a indovinare sbagli hai perso
marrone di mamma ingrediente colori era
meglio se lo sbagliavi perché per far se
avete mai notato l'uomo aspetti non so
se mi spiego
allora l'unico colore un po marrone qui
è questo che anche un bel colore quindi
se anche fortuna non è giusto però
smettila della casata la salubrità
non è giusto né marrone marrone o addio
di mezzo tantissimo è un bellissimo
colore io sono stato bravo non è gettato
un ingrediente che poi utilizza quindi
può tornare utile anche il mio si può
utilizzare anzi alla fine non ti è
uscito proprio marrone ma un bellissimo
colore metallizzato dall'invaso allora
che come possa scegliere per vendicarmi
di tutto questo due parole da 50 razza
anche i stiva proviamo con la paura
abbiamo contestato l'impiccato l'angolo
si vede si si si si
[Applauso]
fammi vedere dove è solo all'inizio e
solo l'inizio
[Musica]
be nice
noi facciamo il corpo dell'impiccato si
vede r
meno male però se come backing come una
lettera così lunga così lungo iscritti a
a meno male provate a indovinare anche
voi nei commenti
g non c'è ora quindi facciamo un braccio
sto per perdere se perdo vitale potrà
decidere cosa mettere slime l
cioè se le due è l a
cipolla on line torna vi dirò sì ma
grigia no vi si non mi dire che cosa è
eccola mentre la m ma sa benissimo che
hai vinto non è colla verme e con la
verde verde però attenzione essere su
tre con le verdi da scegliere perché c'è
questa che è fuffa fluorescente che sta
qui alla spalla che fulmina la
telecamera io pensavo che potete
sceglierlo in questo non ti prendevano
la bolla verde e avessi perso prezzi
comunque questo da quella verde
quindi no a cannes certo resta ancora
più fatto verdissimo permettere la colla
verde nel mio bicarbonato
ecco fatto di più negativa che vogliono
fare a meno cara come anita già sia
un'altra volta che questa è andata già
avanti io invece indovinato così vita
perché a me vediamo mettere male con
quel colore sette lettere l'aria ora la
terza lettera è una trovata indovinare
anche voi ai bambini bicarbonato nora a
ecco con la tua testa adesso il
bicarbonato di sodio bicarbonato di
sodio di soldi
eccola la f forse ho capito
ah sì
mi sono resa conto che hanno sbagliato
una cosa ma vabbè non fa niente ti
ricordi no io ho capito che cos'è o
sentono milano già da subito
vediamo se lo sharp ha sbagliato perché
non scritta in inglese che in italiano
ma lo sapete che mi confondo sempre tra
l'inglese l'italiana cosa è parte anche
tutto il team confuso come ha poi
dominato in giappone con una deriva che
mettevi quello verde ma non posso
decidere io che hanno dominato da apple
c'era qui l'altro shampoo verde ai mezzi
che sono appunto lato cosa marroncino
marrone musica e colore diventa brutta
troppo ne ho messo troppo bene secondo
me è una volta che limitiamo qui saranno
o religioso per il colore giallo 7
esattamente
allora vediamo l di livorno già c'è un
wow e udine
ha fatto la testa di palermo grazie a
questo senso del corpo dal challenge sta
andando molto male per me fondamentale
mettere sulla estera prova con la wood e
vitale non mi fido di te va bene
proviamo vi di evitare per farci perdere
viti bologna però perdere
mancano solo due altre possibilità e se
distruzione per lenti non c'è una
attenzione l'ultimo tentativo brava
brava
ti di torino così forse posso provare a
indovinare il ltv la famiglia rimette
niente è di empoli cioè lette lattes
slice blatter
forse in mente una cosa si dissero va
capita soli grid
ma che guarda guarda ultimo tentativo
della nostra terra
allora vediamo cosa posso scegliere
certo con il verde non ci sta bene un
bel niente
ometto i glitter birdie ma non posso
mettermi a interventi il rischio di
mettere questi o quelli rossi ma questi
qua però quelli rossi secondo me ci sono
mi aspetto questi dorati sono più cari
magari facciamo già lo slam natalizio
ecco fatto ai cinque lettere prova a
indovinare
sono stata molto brava per te per questo
turno permettere la migliore dal cec ha
ammesso di simone è che la tua testolina
equa della sd simone nemmeno se due
verso così l'ha nemmeno da canova bravo
ci credo
la bibbia e non posso dire niente
l'audio otranto va bene la giudicato
attenzione posto e la tua risposta
definitiva nuova troppo troppo
pericolosa ingrediente è il posto chri
chri chri chri milione sodio per all
estero già detto no le mie risposte
rispetto dei diritti non puoi dare le
risposte non sono definiti giorno che
avevo avvisato
lo fanno è sogno
hai sbagliato non perderà la scusa per
mettere la cosa live invece di scegliere
secondo me sceglierai quella viola
guarda capi diventa bello varrà è bello
così adesso che uscirò beccarsi a palla
gol non li mettete voi la watts
indovinata ora era invaso il momento di
mischiare vi facciamo vedere come sono
mischiati poi gli attivi a volo vediamo
di vincere è che il mio slime sembra un
po una schifezza speriamo che questo
colore ora lo migliori vediamo
tra l'altro se già il bicarbonato quindi
stanno facendo tutti i gruppi no perché
brutto è brutto ma vediamo una volta
attivato magari migliora si trova a 13
milioni ma le sembra un albero di natale
invece tale dai dai che sta per
diventare stampo orientale ora no ma ora
sembra delizioso io speravo cisse galaxy
kakà nick the nightfly news live
verdolino devo dire che è un po un po di
glee è uscito ma non sembra più un po un
po brutto fallo di troppo e verde riina
con i glitter oro ma non è uscito molto
bene perché non c'era molta colla quindi
è vestito un po un pomeriggio
questo è il mio time vediamo era quella
di vitale dove io per prima cosa vorrei
asciugare qua prima che mi mi rovini il
mio slime bellissimo bello un colore che
sembra una meraviglia vi presento slime
mousse di cioccolato che bello non
sembra proprio mostre e perché la davis
ha lasciato un po di colore ex casa del
tau
diciamo che anche il mio non è che sia
proprio fantastico
sembra che si stia distrugge il tuo
cuore più brutto per passata perché no
non è vero cioccolato a lei frings dello
slide budino zoe dal nostro bellissimo
allora belli ma se vi piace lo standard
e votate per la vita altrimenti votato
il mio che il team confuso team confuso
qui in alto a destra
anche questo dato 6 vinto io vitale
anche se entrambi abbiamo fatto però
sono super divertenti mirato hanno
lasciato un bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo
fatto cantare per vedere il trealbe
video clicca scusa è buona